Dr. Tarun Mittal is a
surgeon in New Delhi.
He's fighting on the front lines
of an epidemic quietly
sweeping India, driven
by a new menace:
junk food.
We reduce the size of the stomach,
which is called a sleeve gastrectomy.
We have operated from
age of 13 till the age of 74.
Initially, when I joined my practice,
I was seeing maybe one
or two patients a month.
Now I am seeing
15 to 20 patients a month.
In India, almost one in four adults
is considered overweight or obese.
If nothing changes, the country’s
obesity rate
is set to increase by more
than 80% by 2035.
This is not simply a story of individuals
making unhealthy lifestyle choices.
In India, and much of the
world, larger economic
and social forces are threatening
people's health and prosperity.
Much of India's history has been blighted by famine.
As recently as 1943, the Bengal famine
killed up to three million people.
Even now, roughly a third of children
suffer from stunted growth.
And yet, over the last three
decades, obesity has surged.
And it's set to get worse.
That’s been accompanied by a rise
in cardiovascular disease and diabetes.
The economic costs are enormous.
Premature deaths, health care costs
and productivity losses
resulting from an overweight population
are estimated to top
$129 billion by 2035,
almost 2% of its GDP.
It's a double burden
of malnutrition now.
Malnutrition means under and over.
Now we are seeing a lot of
overnutrition as well.
Dr. Arun Gupta is a pediatrician
and health campaigner.
He is the co-author
of The Junk Push,
a report detailing how changing food consumption threatens health.
Since globalization, the marketing of processed and ultra-processed food
has picked up.
That has actually influenced
a lot of dietary habits.
One of the major inputs
here is unhealthy diet comprising of ultra
ultra-processed foods, high in sugar, high in saturated fat,
or high in salt or sodium.
Throughout the country,
home-cooked meals are losing out
to empty calories and sugar.
In the span of a decade,
India's consumption of
breakfast cereals and potato chips
have more than tripled,
while confectionary items
and soda sales have doubled.
India is a massive emerging market
for Western brands.
Sales of ultra-processed snack food
and sugary beverages
grew from $6.2 billion in 2009
to $32 billion in 2022.
For companies like Nestlé, Unilever
or Kellanova,
sales are growing at double-digit rates.
And who one are of the main targets?
Whenever we go to a party,
suppose a birthday party of
one friend, there'll be various
junk food items such as Coke, Pepsi.
I really enjoy Maggi,
and I like noodles and ramen.
Burger King, McDonald's.
Maggi.
Pasta.
Chips.
Burgers.
Pizza.
That is very delicious.
India's new food economy has created
a public health conundrum,
with the packaged food
and beverages industry increasingly
affecting the diets of 1.4 billion Indians.
One remedy that other countries have turned to is stricter regulation.
Chile, for example,
has an advertising ban
on television on certain foods
between 6 a.m. and 10 p.m.
It also has restricted
the use of child-targeted imagery
in the marketing of these products.
After these interventions were introduced,
sugary drink sales dropped by 24%,
as well as calorie consumption,
calories from sugar,
and calories from saturated fat.
Until now, India has mostly relied on the companies themselves self-regulating
how they convey the nutritional
value of their products.
The results, some argue, are misleading.
If you you see the front of the pack,
you will see that they claim that
it's like 50% of vitamin D.
Rich in vitamin C, no added preservatives.
And it says very brightly, 20% protein.
But if you look at the back of the label,
you find that 46% of it is sugar.
More than 13 grams of sugar.
Stabilizers, colors and flavors.
If you are telling people
that it is high in protein,
you very well tell them it is
high in sugar and high in fat, also.
Efforts are underway to introduce
a more rigorous system.
Throughout 2021 and 2022,
Indian authorities consulted
health and consumer rights experts,
and representatives of food companies,
about a new labeling system.
While health and consumer rights groups argued for a traffic light system,
used by much of Europe,
which signals red for products
high in sugar, fat or salt,
the eventual conclusion by the authority
was for a Health Star Rating,
which assigns star ratings for a product's
overall nutritional value.
Not everyone was happy.
Health Stars only point that this food is
either healthy or less healthy.
It doesn't tell people
that it is unhealthy.
For example, a pack of cookies
may have a very high amount of sugar.
But, if the manufacturers add nuts,
it could get awarded a star
for containing fiber.
Getting that regulation right
has been evading us in the country.
So that is one part of the story.
But what we are missing out is
working at community level,
with children, with parents, families
to create an environment
for healthy eating
and sustainable food environments.
Pawan Agarwal runs
the Food Future Foundation,
a nonprofit that seeks to educate
schoolchildren about healthy eating.
The foundation
runs programs in schools like this one
in order to educate children and parents.
It is so important to focus
on preventive strategy
and use diet and lifestyle
as the entry point for this intervention.
Government or any regulatory body
cannot reach out to individual citizens
at all mealtimes.
So at the end of the day,
this is about individual choices.
While nutrition advocates
seek tighter regulation,
that may run at odds with
Prime Minister Narendra Modi’s
strategy to attract more investment
from multinational companies.
The fear among health experts
is that the burden will ultimately fall
upon people to make
healthy choices on their own,
with little guidance from the government.
One of the tactics they use is
putting the onus on the people.
That it is the people
who are choosing to eat wrong foods.
It's not us.
Which, probably is one of the strategies
which they have been
using for tobacco, also.
That people are smoking by
their choice and not because
of the marketing.
What cigarette do you smoke, doctor?
The brand named most was Camel.
Smoke Camels. The cigarette so
many doctors enjoy.
The tactic is: industry will become
a part of the solution.
They want to be a part of the solution.
They enter into policymaking bodies.
Of course, the government
allows them to do so,
as stakeholders.
Strict regulations and education
have driven down
smoking rates across the globe.
Imposing controls on the food
industry may be necessary
to fight India's surging obesity rates
and the illnesses that it causes.
Diabetes, hypertension, joint pains, back pain, varicose veins, gallbladder stone,
hernia, cancers, infertility,
chest problems, heart problems.
It is putting an enormous
strain on our economy.
A country once
blighted by too few calories,
must face a new battle
with too many empty ones.